rise and grind it's a new day full of
new opportunities new possibilities
sean cannell here with think media and
i'm excited because we
are hiring and in this video i'm going
to be talking about
our mission here at think media the five
c's that we look for
in team members as well as details
um if you think that this would be a
good fit for you so that you can
apply and if you want to go straight to
it you can just go to work with
think dot com to see current positions
available i will also be answering your
questions
couple disclaimers uh number one i i
think that you will get value out of
this video
if you just kind of want to learn about
what maybe a ceo or a leader looks for
in team members so you could be
better prepared i think for any position
number two if you are
a leader or you lead an organization um
you might get some insights
over some of the distinctions that we
have for the team members here at think
media
and then number three maybe you actually
want to work at this company and hey why
not get to know each other first
to see if it'll even be a good fit and
you might be like dude i don't want to
work with that guy
then that would be good to know right
now wouldn't it and so um i hope you get
a lot of value out of this video
and this is kind of a uh just straight
from the heart
heather and her family from the fake
media team they're camping this weekend
mel's hanging out with family uh we have
a strong work ethic at think but also a
strong
rest ethic at think media and so uh this
is an unsanctioned live stream that i'm
just coming to you or if you're watching
on the replay smash the like button and
we'll get straight into it what's up
becca ralph
tony here we go um number one before we
get into the five c's that we look for
in think media team members
is our mission what are we doing here at
think media well um
our mission is to help 10 000 people
create a full-time living doing what
they love while making a difference in
the world
with youtube and experience that success
without losing their soul and so
you know this kind of comes out of my
story why why are we on a mission to do
this well
back if you haven't heard my story in
2009 my wife almost died
and we were going through the hardest
season of our life we were losing our
homes with the big short
we had a rental property in the house we
were living in our church was falling
apart because
of a lack of character and strong
leadership
which has become one of my big passions
and we'll talk about that
um and and then of course my wife's
health is under attack and at the time
were dual income
and i needed to level up as a leader and
i was like god why is this happening but
what are we gonna do
so i had been studying youtube i started
a youtube channel for my church in 2007
and i've been studying affiliate
marketing and i i thought i'm going to
not for fame or for fortune those things
are cool too
but i to provide for my family and to
pay for medical bills i'm going to
figure this youtube thing out i want to
work from home i want to build a life on
my own terms
and because i was able to do that i was
able to build a six figure income as a
small town kid
college dropout shooting videos in my
bedroom talking about tech and doing
affiliate marketing
it completely transformed my life so now
our company mission
is to transform other people's lives
so our mission is to help people and we
really believe
that we want to specifically help 10 000
and eventually beyond that and
to actually do something similar to be
able to work from home
build a side income a part-time income
but even more so
we say we want to help purpose-driven
people we believe there's people that
have messages that matter
we believe that there's a lot of evil
and darkness in the world right now we
want to empower people with messages of
good
and life and amplify that on what we
think is the most powerful platform
that's youtube we also want to create
wealth
for families for communities to pay
taxes
for for nations uh and and then to be
able to be generous
um you can't really give out of lack but
we you can give out of overflow
and that is the value of ours we want to
help causes that matter
we are a mission-driven company we
support 35 kids right now as a company
through compassion international in
terms of feeding
education housing uh in developing
nations and kids that are really in need
even through covid we we added more
our dreams to get to 100 as soon as
possible um
and we also build leaders and we want to
build leaders not just on our team but
hopefully hopefully through our content
and even go deeper than youtube like we
think it starts with youtube but youtube
is small business youtube is
entrepreneurship youtube is leadership
because you got to put yourself out
there you got to get over
insecurity you got to get over fear and
you got to put out
you know content and you have to learn
new skills that's leadership and we
believe the world needs more leaders so
that's some of our mission
um we want to be in the top 10 companies
to work for in nevada where we are based
even though people do work remote
we want to be in the top 2 of our
industry in terms of influence and
excellence that's a good signal right
there of the kind of people we're
looking for
we want to be in the top 2 in our
industry in terms of influence
and excellence we want to build a team
of world-class
leaders expressing their creativity
collaborating effectively and crushing
their targets together
eventually and as we're doing right now
we want to build a team of personalities
with life-changing content across
multiple platforms so our vision goes
beyond
just the tech that we do right now we
can see multiple think media
personalities
across multiple platforms of technology
marketing business leadership health
faith and life
for example heather's bigger mission is
she wants to see change in
families and she wants to uh be a good
leader
an example of her and isaiah of great
leaders raising up strong families
um we eventually see think media think
media certified coaches beyond
our core team of coaches right now these
are some of the things we want to
to do in the future so it's a little bit
of our mission and we have a big mission
we have
we want to we want to change the world
we want to put make a dent in the
universe
we want to help people um and so if you
could see yourself being a part of that
um here are the five c's of what we look
for in our team members and if you're
getting value smash like if you've got a
question throw out four question marks
before
and after your question i would love to
answer your questions
about working at think media and if you
go to work with think
dot com it should be in the text or in
the youtube description
i'm streaming this everywhere across all
of our platforms and groups
just because we actually would most like
to work with
somebody who already knows us knows what
we stand for has been watching our
content maybe you've already
gone through video ranking academy
that's a bonus maybe you've already
you know watched our videos or you
listen to our podcast every week
you know if you don't that's fine but it
sort of is like
it would be a huge signal you know that
you already
love the mission or love the company and
would want to be a part of things
because you already
you know are kind of involved with what
we're doing and so um
sharing this across our platforms let's
talk about it
five c's and i think this will help you
in general so i think you'll get value
out of this video the first one's
character
like kind of goes without saying but you
got to say it
like it doesn't matter if you're the
best in the world at what you do and
your skills are so amazing
if you don't have character you don't
have anything
and so what does character mean it means
your word is your bond right like
what you say you can be trusted uh
definitely not dishonest or shady or
like you say one thing not flaky
uh so your word is your bond if you say
you're gonna do something you do it
right you say you're gonna be there
you're there
character to us means you take extreme
ownership um
it means that if you were given an
option
to there was an issue in the company you
know issue in your work or somebody's
works there was a problem
do you blame others or do you take
responsibility
and real leaders even if
it may be somebody else's responsibility
they usually still take up and take
responsibility great book to read is
extreme ownership by jocko willing
it's about taking extreme ownership of
course it's not about being delusional
but it's about guarding others
and some people have this proclivity and
propensity to blame everything on
everybody else
you won't fit at think media with that
by the way from here on out
if you're easily offended you might want
to stop watching the video
because if if you feel like this
is in contradiction to your character
and it offends you
it's probably a good thing because we
wouldn't want you to work and think
anyways and so
uh if you want to keep leaning in this
is we have pretty high standards and i
think we should
in life i think that our life organizes
around the standards that we set and we
really care about our company culture
we are a family at think media and so we
protect that family extreme ownership
or whatever it takes attitude or
whatever it takes attitude
character the first c is character
somebody type it in the chat trustworthy
and trust trustworthy is like not just
that you can keep a secret or something
trustworthy is more like just you
actually follow through and do what you
say you're gonna do
like i'm gonna get it done it gets done
um you also represent the company
right and so i know there's some
companies that
um especially in you in the youtube
culture that are like just wild you know
what i mean it's just like hey
let's party let's be crazy and we aren't
here to
police anybody's morality but you
represent the company
and so your your character your
reputation
you know if you're loyal on time hard
working
um and uh you know if you're throwing up
like middle fingers and like
you know you've got like
i don't know prostitutes like just
throws the word out there
no disrespect to sex workers like just
ultimately saying if you're if you're
just like living this crazy
potential image it just might not fit
with our brand and i think you probably
get our brand
wow got weird told you you might get
offended all right strong work ethic
uh follow through listen character to us
is actions speak louder than words and
in the hiring process
here's what we understand here's how our
hiring process works
um you get to me at the last stage so
melissa caputo is going to review the
first thing see if you even just fit
and then you'll probably go through a
couple zoom meetings and then eventually
you'll meet with heather maybe jordan
some other people
and then eventually you'll meet with me
for like a long time like we hire slow
so we really want to get to know people
and whatnot
and i know it's easy to talk well up at
the beginning it's kind of like dating
isn't it you know what i mean you're on
your best behavior when you're on those
first couple dates but then eventually
you get married you're like oh
and we're not talking about perfect
people here man we we are messed up at
think media
on our own but we've probably been
around people who talk big talk
but don't actually follow through with
the big action and so
uh so action is more important than
talking for us all right respectful
you know what i mean like respectful to
each other your co-workers
um clear communication we believe
character is clear communication have
you ever been around somebody that like
you've been frustrated
because they didn't communicate clear so
next thing you know like you showed up
to the place you're like oh yeah i
wasn't going to be there six so it's
going to be there at eight you're like
i'm here two hours early like
it matters like clear communication
verbal and written skills this is just
character in my opinion
good attitude we believe that attitude
is a choice
if you show up on even zoom meetings
camera on
and you're like you look like you just
got hit by a truck
last night you had you know 10 old
fashions
um if that's the case but you can still
keep it together you know
but you got to show up like attitude
like do you bring
i know on oprah's door she has a sign
oprah winfrey it says be mindful of the
energy
that you bring into the room like before
you come into my office like be mindful
of the energy that you're bringing into
the room
and and that matters on zoom in my
opinion like
dude you don't even have a commute you
don't have traffic your commute is from
your keurig machine to your shower to
your home office because we work from
home
and if you can't be locked in loaded
ready to go
at 9 00 a.m now different time zones i
get that
dude you got issues man i mean there's
maybe another company for you but you
got to be able to have a good attitude
and it's a choice
it's not that people don't have bad days
i told you that is this offensive let me
know
offensive hey you're watching my hiring
video for my company thank you for being
here
uh self-motivated this is a big deal
because
at this point we don't have an office
culture so you don't have somebody over
your shoulder motivating you you got to
be self-motivated you got to be able to
get things done
and character is realizing that when
you're working from home
you know i talked to a friend of ours
who's a 17 year old doing remote
covered learning and she's like dude
this thing is a freaking joke
she's like my friends uh
log in say hello turn their camera off
and go back to bed
she's like none of my friends are going
to these classes on zoom
so how much more on a team
or when you work for a company dude it's
easy when you work remote you might be
able to try to get away with a lot if
that's your attitude
this is not the right company for you
got to be self-motivated you want to be
driven to produce results in your role
we are not micromanagers we don't want a
micromanaging one we want
leaders that are in niche that have
initiative that get things done and are
self-motivated
i believe common sense is part of
character
common sense because common sense is not
that common
and so common sense is let me give you
some practical instructions
if at by this point you still actually
think you might want to work at think
media
don't dm me your resume don't dropbox me
a video don't send me an audio message
on instagram
don't dm heather don't text message
somebody that you know on the team
go to workwiththink.com and read the
application and fill it out and if you
read it and you go this isn't actually
me
then at this point those jobs might not
be a fit for you
don't tweet me don't clubhouse me
we have a particular system and that's
here's character ability to follow
instructions
and a lot of people just kind of like a
hint
they disqualify themselves when applying
for jobs and i hope that this helps you
when working applying for other jobs and
even to talk to leaders
you should give a couple like at the end
of a paragraph you might put a little
easter egg there to see if the person
just scans the application and quickly
submits the resume or actually reads
every word
are you going to treat this position
with attention to detail
what's your ability to follow
instructions and so
the way to apply is work with think.com
not dm anyone not not your version of
where you uploaded your resume
go through the process we believe all of
that's character hey is everybody happy
right now
is this too hardcore or do you like our
you like our culture here
uh follow instructions exactly you gotta
follow
instructions and um okay that's just the
first c
that's just the first c and i like that
where i feel like we're on the same page
jordan
yep remote remote work defines who the
real leaders are we are now
accountable to our own self-leadership
some will rise above
and those will stand out my man you're
describing the type of people we want to
work with to think
we're just on uh we're just on character
right now we're just on character
there's five c's number two chemistry
chemistry are you compatible with our
culture now here's the thing with this
one
we don't think we're the only company of
course we
aren't we don't think we're the only way
of doing something of course we are i
don't think
that my poop doesn't stink that's the
only way
like dad a five-month-old like that's
the only example
like dude i'm i got i got bad breath in
the morning is what i'm trying to trying
to get to
and so chemistry just means do you fit
with our culture
because we know there are incredible
people in the world that just don't fit
on every ten you understand that you're
like you might fit in one place and not
as much in another place it's about
finding that chemistry
and that compatibility with a certain
culture like we've had some great people
work for think
and they discovered that they actually
wanted more of a corporate environment
more of kind of they wanted they wanted
like and we're a lot better at this now
like uh because now we're about 13
people we've been doing this five years
but we're very much a startup we're
still putting things together
and they they were when this person
first joined they were like do you have
like an employee handbook with all your
policies and procedures and we were like
no
we don't i think we do now but my point
is
that we were in such a startup
flexibility like you got to just jump on
and and that doesn't fit some people's
personalities and that's not bad
you gotta you gotta know if you're after
character if you check the character box
do you fit with our culture and that's
why we'll go through the whole
interviewing process
work with think.com if you want to apply
for one of the four positions
and any future positions we'll all be at
work with think.com what is our
chemistry number one work hard and play
hard
we work really hard we also believe in
playing hard um
but my mom taught me do the hard thing
first so
we love to reward our team we did some
cool things last year
even though there were some limitations
with covid restrictions we got a summer
leadership
meeting thing coming up we'll take a
couple days and we
will probably you know we'll jet ski a
little bit and we'll we'll do some
leadership talks we'll cook together
we'll hang out
we really believe in playing hard but
after we work hard
we believe in celebrating results this
is a good personal discipline
that i don't think it's good to
celebrate
and on the other side of you were lazy
first it's you should you should have a
culture of celebration
on the other side of crushing it
personally crush it
and then celebrate your wins crush it so
we
we do believe in rest we don't want we
don't we believe in sleep
we're not trying to burn anybody out we
expect people to work full-time people
to work like 40 hours a week
like like a honest amount of time you
know
uh we're not trying to say it's some
crazy and and so my rise and grind
instagram stories may indicate that like
we have some kind of a like
insane and they're seasons growth video
live and you get this if you've ever
worked on a team
that does events or of course there's
seasons where
there's a really long work days because
you have a live event or we do a
challenge
but our day to day is that we want to
work hard
in the allocated time it's character
that you work when you say you're gonna
work and that we also
rest hard that's part of our culture
good with people we work hard but we
have fun in the process
we like people who can uh can kind of
vibe
kind of like that understand humor and
uh
and and that you're good with people a
good communicator
um and uh that's part of our culture
positive and encouraging this is our dna
there's some cultures that are kind of
critical maybe kind of negative
sometimes even like cynical like the way
like siblings bicker they kind of like
make fun of each other
you know or whatever we're positive
encouraging we
there are certainly on the think media
team where we maybe
joke at like little things i think
that's healthy just like a family would
do but
overall we're positive and encouraging
we speak life not death over others
um and when we identify problems we
choose to see the possibilities
and pursue possibilities you know every
day i say rise and grind it's a new day
of
new opportunities and new possibilities
this isn't forced optimism
or delusional positivity it is a
decision
to recognize there are plenty of
problems in our world there's plenty of
problems in our company there's
plenty of problems and challenges ahead
of us but we're going to choose to see
the possibilities and pursue
possibilities
and choose to see the bright side and
choose to look for solutions not dwell
on challenges and problems so for
example when you're when you're on the
team it's not like
i'm stuck here's a problem i'm stuck
here's a problem by the way we're very
of course very helpful but the the goal
is like well if you're bringing me a
problem bring three solutions along with
it
like constantly be a problem solver
constantly be a solution finder that is
our our culture
and you're gonna be very empowered uh to
to to pursue solutions
like a lot a lot of times leaders want
to micromanage i don't
want to you bring a problem i'm like
well what do you want to do
sean can you help me with this i don't
know how to solve it what do you want to
do you know so if
self-motivated problem-solving
figure-out-able
like you would be surprised kyle
anderson and i used to work at a church
together
and he was much younger than so was i
and uh he would come into my office
oftentimes and and it would be with like
a video editing software problem like
he'd be like hey how do i jump cut the
thing
and he knew that i would just look at
him with disdain on my face
and i'd be like write this down
g o
o g
l and then in shame he would turn away
and walk back down the hall i'm like
dude
google it dog like why you can't walk
down the hall with every
and that was that's the way i figured
things out we live in an
age of information at your fingertips so
our
our chemistry and our culture right
being able to vibe with our culture is
you're a figured out person
you're a problem solved person you know
how to wipe your own butt
wow offensive sean uh you know how to
uh google your own things and it's not
that we're not collaborative so of
course we collaboratively solve problems
but hear me if like every single time
you get stuck
you need to be micromanaged then we are
gonna it's gonna slow us down we gotta
go fast man
okay let's speed up grateful that's our
our chemistry grateful
we speak a lot of life into others we
believe that we should encourage one
another every single day
and so grateful uh humble no egos
um we're also we don't have false
humility we don't like pretend
if we just crushed it that we didn't
crush it that's false humility
we want to be sober about judging
ourselves but like
but it's not an ego's silos territorial
type of thing
we our culture is gratitude humility and
we pursue a healthy culture versus a
toxic culture
sam chan wrote a book called the culture
code uh the advantage patrick
leoncione why organizational health
trumps everything
and so we pursue organizational health
we believe that our company moves at the
speed of
the health of the culture so you've
probably been in a toxic culture before
where maybe
there it felt like there wasn't clear
communication maybe people
spoke talk behind other people's backs
maybe there was weird nepotism
we are a meritocracy what does that mean
a meritocracy means we reward people
based on their merit based on the
results they get
that should be how you are confident not
because
you're my son sean bradley cannell
notice this that sean bradley cannon
will not just become
a ceo at think media someday just
because he's my son
he will have to earn it have worked for
it demonstrated the character traits
necessary
and maybe you've been a part of an
organization where there was nepotism
shown to family members well that builds
resentment amongst team members because
they go well that person just got it
because of how they were born
or because of how they look versus the
content of their character and the
results they produce
so a healthy culture we believe is
uh one where we try to rid those toxic
elements
any kind of negativity or deception
or or weird stuff and you've maybe
worked for an unhealthy team or
or whatever you've maybe worked where
whatever goal is a healthy culture
and and what we've learned is that you
know it's kind of like
if if you go into a toxic environment
and you are healthy you immediately feel
it it's like a plant goes into like a
room of poison you're like
and then vice versa if you're in a
healthy garden
and something toxic comes in there's so
much health in the garden it either
repels that thing or that thing actually
gets corrected
and so we're we're on a healthy culture
mode um
next morals and ethics that's just where
we come from uh
morals ethics constant growth that is
our chemistry
to be honest if you and this is to be
clear
this does not have to be everyone's
chemistry i know you know that
we believe that lifelong leaders are
lifelong learners and here's the deal we
believe that to win on youtube and in
the digital landscape
in the ever-changing world of social
media and digital
you can't be standing still you have to
be constantly growing
reading leveling up not everybody reads
we have an
audible account people do audiobooks we
have we buy online courses for our team
we basically have an unlimited education
budget
for our team members to buy online
courses books and audio books and
whatnot to support
that constant growth and so uh there's
seasons of course where it's pure grind
and maybe not as much study
but we believe that healthy things are
growing and so
constant growth that is our culture
flexible comfortable with change
we're getting better because now we have
a bigger team but
like things could change by the way so
does the world
march 2020 we were like whoa what the
heck last year right the
covet happened things were happening so
we flipped the flop and flopped the flip
and changed some things up
you got to be ready to be like hey
here's what we're doing now and we we
also double down
in desperation for our lives as the
economy shutting down and things like
that
we went from for example the content
creators which we're not hiring for
right now
um went from two video
like one video a week each from la and
vegas team to two it was like it's time
to grind man
i hope we still are in business in a
couple months and we had our best year
ever
but you got to be flexible comfortable
change
if you want to just have a cookie cutter
it's the same thing every day
i want to know exactly what everything
is and i never want to be surprised with
changes this is not the company for you
so that's why we're hopefully you're
still here
and you might go okay i i really don't
like tons of change
and it's not like it's tons of change
and i hope you hear my heart well
whatever i don't need to justify
anything
it's my company this is how it is
uh but i am empathetic by not trying to
pivot constantly or change constantly
i'm constantly trying to work on my own
leadership
um and all that to say is you gotta know
that sometimes
you might be like oh shoot we're going a
new direction because
the the reason we would be going in a
new direction would always be explained
for to seize an opportunity to to make
you get it
and then finally we are a leadership
culture so we
we don't want we believe that leaders
create leaders not more followers
so we're not looking for like a top
heavy organization where there's a
couple
leaders that are waiting for instruction
from everybody else we actually we
just want all leaders and if that's a
term you're not used to hearing
if it's a term you haven't studied a lot
if you're watching this video
no matter what happens in your future
our company whatever
it will benefit you to grow your
leadership if you've never read a book
on leadership
today's the day to change that um
because
taking on the identity if you go i'm not
a leader well that's your choice because
everyone
can be a leader you got to first lead
yourself self-leadership
which is character you got to lead your
family
you might be the leader amongst your
friends you know
and not everyone is called like gifted
with the same leadership in terms of
their dna or genetics but every single
one of us can raise our leadership
ability
so we are constantly trying to push
decisions down into the organization
empower
others and we want problem solvers
leaders not more followers
i don't want a bunch of people around me
or in this case
around heather or mel or other people in
the company that are constantly just
like waiting to be told what to do
it's about you actually being empowered
to lead
and so i hope that is clear and let me
know if you have any questions we'll get
to those in a second smash
like if this is valuable chilling on a
saturday hanging out talking about
the five c's the first one was character
the second one was chemistry let me know
what your aha moment is right now too
uh if you have any aha moments i haven't
said hello for a second
um and uh any aha moments that maybe
even for yourself your own career your
own job maybe how you could step up in
your own job
um and and how does
uh does this sound like crazy
to you uh here we go evan leadership is
a choice
growing leadership skills is so
important leadership is so important in
society today i agree and we we
definitely want to
to uh uh build that out
jennifer thank you just share the job
things
blessed are the facts flexible that is
one of our dna points evan
blessed are the flexible those who bend
and don't break
that's our culture okay cool what's an
aha moment though
oof chelsea nicole what are your
favorite leadership books don't even get
me distracted chelsea
uh 17 laws uh 21 laws of leadership john
maxwell
um and uh 17 laws of teamwork john
maxwell
pretty much everything john maxwell the
leader's greatest return
is really oh here you go 21 irrefutable
right there
uh the bible
is my favorite one and it's actually the
the john maxwell leadership bible so it
kind of just reads the whole bible
through
the lens of leadership um so much good
bad
ugly lessons that can really help grow
in leadership so a big john maxwell fan
craig groschel leadership podcast
man what are some of the best leadership
books those are some good ones to start
with
um um
simon sinek uh the infinite game uh
leaders e last
simon cynic uh and and and
i'll make a think marketing podcast
about that that's a good combo
and maybe we'll put yeah we'll put
something okay so the first one's
character
if you've made it through wisdom test
number one character
wisdom test number two chemistry again
do you fit with our culture are you
compatible with our culture number three
competency so
to us let me clarify two things during
this hiring session
competency in the digital marketing
youtube space
i actually we're always looking for good
people if you
are what i just described which i
realize is a pretty high standard
we we believe you can learn things of
course you can
but like i think about melissa caputo
who today on our team
is one of the best copywriters email
marketers
uh page builders funnel builders um
social media marketers uh
leaders a lot of things i met her at
growth video live one we just had growth
video live three virtual so she's been
at her company for about three years
and she had the first two she had done
some social
she had helped her within her parents
business she brought a lot of skills but
but listen
she hadn't like done almost any of the
stuff
um because competency
is sort of the new era like you can
learn
i think you could become a great digital
marketer in 24 months if you really put
your head down
and built into it like one of the other
things we're not even hiring for this
right now
but we want a well actually if if you
want to apply for this
then email us or something which i know
i said that's followed instructions oh
no sean
the plane is the ship is sinking listen
we want a shorts person tick tock reels
repurposing content shorts content etc
like somebody that
is thinking shorts youtube shorts and
and that it's like a full
whole thing we want to do um you'd want
to bring some skills to that
but it's also like it's like a new way
of communication right so it's
some but what i'm trying to say is that
when it comes to competency
in the digital marketing space you can't
say you have 10 years of experience in
some cases because certain things
haven't even existed for 10 years
so if you can be a leader and you can
learn quick and you can be adaptable you
can jump in
and in the future we are going to have
another round of like an internship and
what we would consider farm team which
is like
you come in with of course character and
compatibility with our culture
but then you're learning stuff and
that's a different path let me be clear
what we're hiring for these four
positions we are asking
that you already have the competency and
these four positions
right now work with think.com what does
that mean
listen really lean in for this um
what have you built this is where talk
happens all the time on social media
someone's like hey will you hire me
what if you show me what you've already
built
in that area like like we're hiring
part-time administration
uh assistant well sean i've already
built
monday boards i've already built slack
channels and a whole email autoresponder
campaigns
for the inbound that's coming i've
already built
uh two other va's under me at a
different i've already
like when i think about in terms of have
you built a team before
i'm not saying every one of these
positions needs that but what have you
built i've built
five instagram pages to over 10 000
followers i've built
what have you built for competency the
greatest proof
of your ability today is what you've
produced yesterday
so what have you built show me your
portfolio
not every one of these job application
pathways is the same
because you don't need to show us your
portfolio
for the administrative thing because you
probably wouldn't have
that so here's what it is if you go to
work with think.com
right and you you can read through some
of these things
the administrative coordinator uh you'll
see all the details about it and when
you start the application process
i don't think this actually asks you for
um like a resume or a video
it doesn't ask you for a portfolio but
the social media person specialist this
is not like
only like i do my mom's instagram for a
coffee shop we have 55 followers i'm not
trying to be condescending
i'm trying to say have you already built
something
substantial you're coming in for these
positions we are looking for people that
have
have already a portfolio and here's a
massive leadership lesson i learned when
i was speaking at a mastermind in
beverly hills
with neil patel like just trying to like
flex like nobody even knows who that is
okay so um i i was driving and here's
here's a powerful hiring principle for
any leaders
have you already been successful twice
it's just it's so deep have you already
been successful twice
because if you were successful at
something once you might have got lucky
but if you've been able to replicate
that success and build something like a
couple times
then that is evidence they're not
guaranteed but it's evidence she'll
probably be able to do it again
so for these positions have you been
successful twice now you might be like
well i've only worked at one job i
worked with one person for 15 years and
like okay cool
but you get you get the idea it's kind
of like
when i was being interviewed to work as
a director of communications at a church
that was 2 500 people here in vegas
and it was way over my head because i
came from a small town
much smaller church and i remember the
pastor who would be my boss the ceo
basically was like
um he goes he goes sean
what what evidence do you have that you
could help us with our social media and
youtube
um and what how
like show me something that you can i go
well i haven't been in this exact
position before
and so but what i do have is i go i
think that think international
which is a channel that jeff and i
started when we were in the hardest
season a friend of mine he was the youth
pastor who got me into video
ten years ago we started to post videos
we started to create content we started
to interview
on our own volition like we got busy we
were hustling we were ambitious
we were working and we were putting out
content we put over
we put out 250 videos i'm not saying
this is what we're hiring for exactly
what i am saying was i was able to point
to something i built
and say that is proof
substance and artifact that i've done i
think
that considering that you could give me
a chat a chance to do something
at the church and then he hired me so
this is what i mean about the power of
the portfolio
i don't care how well you can write i
don't care
you know if you're like i think i could
pull that off or even if i think i could
learn it and hear me
in the future we will hire kind of in
like an internship or a paid internship
situation
where there will be that educational
grow into a comp com
component but for this like the social
media specialist
like you gotta have built something
like you have to be able to show
that um you could do social media
successfully
and if i am can i have permission to
speak frankly
like the people are like haven't you
been speaking frankly
uh can i can i can i just talk from the
heart
right now um do you mind if i'm frank i
mean you might as well get to know me
now like if you're gonna apply
right is that okay speak frank okay
dude most social media specialists
suck at social media they just do
um social media is one of the i believe
shallowest surface level because anybody
can be like
yeah i set up an instagram
for someone's nail salon and i post
quote cards on there daily
and i've done it for like six months and
i know how to use like canva.com
or this like pixel app to make images
and i can take pictures with my iphone
yeah you and everyone can do that
so when we say social media specialists
this will get you some of my heart from
think media
we're talking about like major
distinctions like you understand
that on instagram it's not just about
getting likes that there's likes
there's saves there's comments there's
shares
that there's words and copy you can use
at the end of post to
encourage people to do those types of
things that you study the
insights that you understand the
connection between
stories and igtvs and the lengths
i saw a social media specialist recently
post on a project i'm involved in
a two plus minute video
on the instagram profile of an instagram
page
where the limit is 60 seconds and the
video just got cut off
and and nobody did anything about it
like i saw it i'm like what are we
talking about here now i
forgive me like turn off the video now
if you're easily offended i was like
this is not this isn't professional but
this but this happens all the time in
social media
in a lot of positions people talk big
and they
don't even it's like they're they're
playing at a kindergarten level and i'm
asking for these four positions
that like you got some depth to it like
you know data details
mastery of platforms and you've built
something so social media specialists
are like a dime a dozen
and a lot of them live on a surface
level and if this cuts you a little bit
that's why i really think this video
could be valuable because you got to
pursue mastery at a higher level if you
want to be in demand
and high paid and always and always
never lacking a job
it's rare to find masters and of course
you got to grow into these things and by
the way when you start working with
heather taurus and melissa caputo like
are you kidding me
like iron sharpens iron you'll be
leveled up quick
but like and here's this comes all the
way back to that ego thing
you got me out here he called me out
upon the waters
to spare my soul
people are delusional like you got to be
self-aware
because i'm stunned by people saying
i'm great at social media here's what's
even more powerful
true humility is like i'm not good at
social media
um i want to get better and
not airing on like self-loathing or like
you know not actually soberly evaluating
your stuff
maybe being like no i i study the
platforms i've built a couple things i
haven't built any super big things but i
want to grow
because one of the things that gets
under my skin quick and you'll learn
this
if you apply for think media
unfortunately your ceo
does this stuff so there's other people
who work
a lot of like you you join like a dog
training company and you're like a
social media specialist you can get away
with all kinds of stuff because that guy
doesn't know the details
dude i freaking have done it all and i
say on the cutting edge of it so
i know a little too you can't really
fake past our team
in terms of what a social media
specialist is all i'm saying is soberly
judge yourself
if you're not a social media specialist
yet you're not a specialist that you're
growing into
it and and hopefully this encourages you
if you want to be like in demand and
always be
employed and always and be growing then
then yeah you're not a specialist you're
a student
and and there will be opportunities
we're deeply passionate about building
leaders and this is a leadership talk as
you can see
um is is is talking at a high level
i don't want to get off on this same
rant but but have you been successful
twice
proof you can actually do it a lot of
people talk big say they can do it
have think that doing it meant the three
instagram accounts they started that
have done nothing
have produced no leads they don't track
any kind of digital marketing metrics
there's no email list to be built
there's no
actual uh continuous study of
of being on the effectatious edge of
what's working in social of
optimizing modern platforms okay so if i
haven't talked you out of applying yet
um this is the competency one for these
four positions
and then finally under competency which
is credibility
capable of getting the job done and
and i guess maybe this is the deal with
us at think media
is we're just not a fluff company like
we might get accused of that on the
surface
but if you like squeeze us you see real
mastery comes out because we work
freaking hard and we really study
and we want to be remember at the two
the top two percent of people in our
industry
so mastery matters to us so it's kind of
there is a difference between playing
t-ball
and between playing in the major leagues
and
when it comes to these four positions at
work with think dot com
i'm not saying you have to necessarily
be heather taurus or melissa caputo in
terms of your social media specialist
skills i'm just saying have you built
something have you been successful twice
and do you pay attention to the details
like
if you're posting two minute videos that
get cut off at 60 seconds
and then you just leave it out there
dude you're not you're just
you're just not a master clearly like
you don't even understand the video
lengths of the
platforms and the resolution sizes let
alone if they're effective or not okay
let's keep it going the three c's shout
them out to me character
number one chemistry number two
competency number three i got two more
for you
hey what's your aha moment uh so far
uh on this have you been challenged uh
and uh have you have you been um
are you comfortable are you
uncomfortable are you happy happy
saturday jennifer says
do a video explaining the difference
between a real social media specialist
and someone who claims to be i like it
there's no way to be an expert on social
media all the platforms change so much
just because
you know how to upload to youtube
doesn't make you any sort of authority
really good jennifer and i agree i think
that'd be a fun one to do with heather
and really talk about those distinctions
and i hope you also hear my heart like
i'm very much this is like leadership
chop it up we're in the locker room man
this isn't this isn't like rah-rah
motivational this is like real talk
i think this is the kind of conversation
people need to hear
like like you gotta you gotta really
like being self-aware to where you are
and not hear me
and not like if by the way if you deal
with
like insecurity in the sense of oh and i
just suck
it's not that either it's just
self-awareness to be like i'm a student
i'm learning
i don't have the ego to be delusional
about where my skills are i understand
where i am and i understand where i need
to grow to
and i understand what the distinctions
are you know if you get me out on a golf
course right now a real golfer is going
to be like dude you're a joke just
because you bought bogey boys macklemore
clothing doesn't mean it's a good
example i i grew up skateboarding
right and we we knew what skateboarders
were called posers
because we would we would buy a
skateboard scrape it on the curb a
little bit so it looked like we actually
grind and like did board slides
but like real recognize real and that's
kind of what i'm talking about here
is it's so trendy to be a social media
specialist it's so trendy to put
expert in your instagram bio it's so
trendy to
to kind of fake it till you make it
um but that's this is not what we're
talking about in this case
um we're looking for real competency
okay
number four number four capacity
shoot we're landing the plane we're
landing the plane
so it's not just competency is the
standard going higher
it's one thing if you can get the job
done it's another thing
if you can get it done quickly okay
i actually remember my dad thank god for
my parents my stepdad phil and my mom
they would have me do chores and i was
like
sweeping off our driveway in arlington
washington up in the country where we
lived
and if you've ever seen like a kid
do like really like pitiful work
like you know like just
and like working like really slow and so
i'm like sweep
swoosh sweet
and my stepdad phil was like what the
hell are you doing like that's literally
what
you know that's how we talk and he'd be
like he'd be like this is how you sweep
the thing
and he would clean off and sweep the
porch
and it only took two minutes to do it at
the pace i was going
it was gonna take freaking 20 minutes
and so
understand the culture of our company
speed matters it's not only can you do
it it's can you do it quickly it's can
you do it repeatedly
it's can you keep doing it over time
i've heard stories and this happens a
lot in churches
because i've done a lot of work in
churches um and
i was a director of communications and
you might see it you might be like okay
i get john's energy he's pretty intense
and by the way work ethic rest ethic see
i
i actually believe
only believe the data backs it up there
is so much inefficiency and laziness in
the american workplace
like ain't nobody getting 40 hours of
work done in 40 hours like
you're going through i'm going to deep
this too like we're all guilty of this
you're not working the whole time
like of course you need time to like
maybe reset or whatever but like the
average productivity and efficiency of
like an american worker is less than 50
percent they may be sitting
in their seats at their desk but they're
not actually effective
and so when i say work ethic and rest
ethic
i just believe if people would actually
work when they're working they would get
so much dang stuff done and then they
could rest when they were resting
and it'd be incredibly effective but
here's what i learned
is is in church culture for church
communicators people who edit like
church videos and they do uh you know
videos social media and stuff for
churches some cultures could be
so grossly underperforming um
that i heard like a friend of mine that
was like working at a church
and he was like the full-time staff like
two full-time people doing video
in 40 hours during like some special
event weekend
didn't sat around did nothing and then
there's these websites where you can buy
a video that's already made and anybody
in in church knows this shift worship or
like these different websites
but the senior pastor wouldn't know so
they would
they just kind of sit around and then
they just like quickly shot like one
little intro thing
and purchased a video offline for like
26 bucks and that was what played on the
weekend
so the outputs that they had to show for
themselves at the end of the week
was one but see what they didn't know
what you wouldn't know and i'm
and and the senior pastor didn't really
know and realized that he had
two lazy and wicked team members
listen uh on his team that that there's
something about
speed and when i is i am aware of what
is possible to accomplish in 40 hours
and what is possible to accomplish in a
good uh workday
i don't expect people to ever be me but
if if it takes me
because i'm a video editor we're not
hiring for video editors
but if it takes me two hours to edit a
video because i'm freaking fast
and it takes a team member four or six
i'm fine with that but listen
if it takes them 20 we have a problem
you know what i mean
and this happens all the time like if it
takes me two like i've been doing it for
a long time of course like
somebody gets faster at something but
that happens more than you would know
capacity speed matters not only can you
do it can you do it quickly
and then can you do it repeatedly can
you keep it going can you sustain that
pace
and then can you keep doing it over time
capacity can you
keep delivering results in your job um
this happens with graphic designers
that's also not what we're
that is what we're hiring for we are
hiring for a graphic designer let me
talk to the graphic designers
digital marketing graphic designer this
is
you got me uh oh you got me on a saucy
saturday
smash the like button
i'm a creative myself um i've had to
grow as a leader and as a ceo
so i understand and maybe i have a grace
i believe
to lead creatives because i am one
because i was i've been in those roles
video editor i am a graphic designer i
design all our thumbnails
we're scaling we need help
i understand that you need your creative
process and that you need to go on a
walk
and like watch the birds and sip your
coffee and listen to your song
on spotify and get in a vibe and mock up
a design
and and mock up a couple different
versions
of your design and then and then submit
those
and then eight hours later or maybe two
days later
you submit your graphics for the project
that we submitted listen that is not our
culture
if it if there's an entire workday and i
need to design
all the graphics and all the facebook
ads uh and all the various versions
and stuff for uh for our um
for like a challenge we're doing like a
youtube influence challenge and i need
to create a thumbnail
like like not that it's anything to flex
on but the we are hiring thumbnail
that i just made for this video just
paint came from a photo shoot i cut
myself out on
on uh uh you know let me show you it i i
cut myself out quickly on photoshop
i i wrote we are hiring i put black
behind it i think it's simple
it's clean and here here's here's what
it is right okay
this this took me 60 seconds and this is
this is probably my exact point
is that graphic designers
there's i've worked with some
that it takes 48 hours
in slack before i get some things back
and i'm like
what do we what do we talk what you do
all day like what have you been
doing and i hope you hear this energy
because if you're going to work
it think like we're fast man and so i
get it if you're going i know that
you're like graphic designers are
offended there's some where you're doing
calligraphy and you need the art and
sean that's so basic
well hear us speed matters and we
actually
like in the time that you make your
piece of art
we just posted four youtube videos did
four different thumbnails
launched four new facebook ads finished
a website with four graphics
that's that's the kind of pace that
we're trying to rock with
and we want to give uh we recognize that
again
i think it's identifying here it's clear
expectations it's identifying that
man we need you to create a logo or
brand well yeah maybe that's going to
take longer
but like hear me on the graphic design
thing
this really matters speed matters this
is capacity
and it goes back to that church thing
too i'm going to design the sermon
artwork i just need to get into a
creative flow
because i'm coming up with a sermon
branding for like my church on the
weekend
what have you been working all week i've
been designing the sermon artwork i've
just been trying to like get into the
zone and the vibe i'm not trying to be
offensive
but this you know this is true and then
at the end 40 hours have gone by and
it's like
i'm still kind of stuck but hey it's my
creative process i think i'll get it
done next week i've went down a couple
directions
like work out your creative process but
meanwhile i think media we're getting
freaking stuff done
and i think that's evident in our
results like our outputs
it has a lot to do with speed speed
matters okay
we're a small nimble and fast moving
company we are a small nimble and
fast-moving company this is capacity
so we also we are we are
ruthlessly trying to uh
cut out red tape so it's we don't also
want
the graphic designer goes through
revision process number one
submits to form waits two days for
approval
waits two days for revisions and
corrections
waits two days until it's what are you
freaking dude the we are hiring
thumbnail was done in 60 seconds dude
like and that's
i hope you hear that even during this
part there's bigger
graphic design than this but but i i've
been in organizations man
and i've worked and coached and
consulted with organizations
where there's so much bureaucracy and
red tape and slowness
that to get a freaking thumbnail done
like that would end up taking
36 hours i decided to do this live
stream
because i finished my coffee we put our
baby down and i was like hey maybe i
should talk about the five c's and we're
hiring right now
flip the thing titled the video
streaming it on stream yard across the
platforms we move fast and you can grow
into that
but understand that's the pace that
we're talking about here at think media
when you work you work you sweep the
porch fast as my stepdad taught me
it's not like sweep ah
take a break
swoosh man look at the sun
and this is a lot of people's pace man
and i hope this helps you too as as just
a creator in general as a solo creator
as a youtuber
if you could probably be five to ten
times more productive than you are right
now
you just could like if you if you got a
different urgency
and a different energy and i'm not
saying
burning yourself out i'm actually saying
you'd be more rested because you just
get more work done in the hours that
you're working
and then you'd rest harder and you'd
feel more refreshed and rejuvenated just
a thought
welcome to everyone's offended saturday
morning with sean cannell
um and then a growing capacity we
recognize
that capacity grows over time i haven't
always been fast at video editing or i
wasn't always able to just
quickly use photoshop but the
expectation is that capacity is growing
and that you don't
come in with this idea of like this is
just my process i'm going to design a
photoshop template
it's my process it's just my process you
know it's just going to take time
okay cool by the way i don't even mean
i'm not actually trying to suggest
that's bad that goes all the way back to
chemistry it might work somewhere else
their pace might be different if you've
been hanging out smart if you do want to
work here
to hang out on this whole stream it's
smart to understand where we're coming
from and so capacity all right
said a lot i got another c for you and
then hit me with some questions
um four question marks before and after
your question
uh and i would love to answer any
questions as we land the plane i got one
more c for you
i hope you're getting value um
out of the video so far and
uh and the faster i do what i get paid
for the more time i spend building my
platform
my man come on speed matters
sean roasting types of people i'm not
trying to roast anybody
uh hey this is my stream jennifer this
is my company
so it which is true um okay
uh nobody is offended because we're
telling the truth a
men don i appreciate you so grateful for
you and yep this is
this is not corporate america this is
speed making
impact work from home youtube culture
social media culture this year we were
like let's
let's be smarter and let's create more
margin and then clubhouse came out and
guess what
in a healthy way it freed me up to be on
clubhouse heather to be on clubhouse the
team's doing things
there is so much happening in this
creative space and what do i mean by
that
is that the reason speed matters is you
get all your work done so you can seize
new opportunities
you get things done quickly so you could
leverage other
opportunities like short form content
youtube shorts so
so we're not just like the the the world
is moving faster
and another good leadership back a book
all the way back to chelsea's question
is leader shift by john maxwell
and leader schiff talks about shifts
necessary to make and he talks about the
world's going faster now
so as leaders we need to think about how
we can also speed up all right
number one we look for character at
think media
here's the five c's number two we look
for chemistry
are you compatible with our culture at
think media number three
we look for competency this is your
credibility meaning you have a
reputation
and you are capable of getting the
specific job
that you apply for that is assigned to
you done competency
number four is capacity speed matters
not just to be able to do your job well
but to be able to do
it well fast repeatedly
and keep doing it over time and then
number five is courage
courage we're looking for action takers
we're looking for people with ambition
that's that's our pace that's our speed
the type of people that
jump right in there and and get messy
i actually have a sign on my wall that
says move fast and break things
we are not a culture at think media that
punishes people for mistakes now hear me
character mistakes yes like if you have
a character mistake
where you break credibility from being
dishonest
then you just don't work at the company
anymore that makes sense
but mistakes because you tested
something or mistakes because you tried
something or mistakes because
you got the website up fast and there
was a misspelling there was a
misspelling on the hiring page for a
second we got it fixed
some people that would trip them out
this sign up on my wall says move fast
and break things so start up culture
it's fast we just run in we believe this
ready
aim fire i mean ready fire aim ready
fire aim
of course don't be careless get ready
make a plan shoot get it out there and
be like all right let's steer the bullet
so that's our culture ready fire aim
like move fast break things adapt
fix it so we're not looking if if your
stance is kind of reserved does not jump
in as not get it done is not
then then that's probably it's probably
not the right position but we're looking
for people who are just get it done
problem solvers action takers ambitious
that that but and i get it you might be
like holy crap like you just talked
everybody out of
applying for think maybe um but but
courage is recognizing of course
it's not the absence of fear it's moving
forward
despite the fear you feel i've been in
over my head a lot i remember when i got
hired at the church lv
2500 people or whatever the attendance
was 40 people on staff
and i i was i was over my head i was
scared like i was scared every day going
to work but i was like
courage and keep learning i was like
devouring leadership books
interviewing friends trying to talk to
people in other positions that are
similar position how can i do better
because because i was really i was
leaning into the fear
leaning in to being ambitious getting it
done
um again if your attitude was
if it's like hey i've been on clubhouse
i've been other places i've been
learning that youtube shorts are a big
deal and we need to start doing youtube
shorts
right if you don't even know what
youtube shorts are something to check
out
if it's like uh when we're already busy
well
we're like already doing so much wow
and i'm not trying to you know hr
call hr i'm not trying to say like
overloading people i'm saying can do
people
it's it's not can we do it it's how are
we going to figure this out it's it's
like
how could we what do we need to do to
make that next thing happen
courage running into battle
running into battle this isn't an age
thing
we hire any age um and it but it reminds
me of caleb in the bible
80 years old i think and pete and the
israelites when it went to go into
the promised land they were like really
timid at the time they're like no
there's giants in the land and
yeah they're gonna devour us we were
grasshoppers in our own eyes
and caleb was like i'm getting my land
man i feel just as energetic today
as i did back then
age is a state of mind and an
energy of your heart it's that young at
heart and it's that i'm still
ready for battle i'm still ready to take
the land i'm still
ready to go into the promised land i am
not small in my own eyes even though i
feel
afraid i am going to charge right
towards the challenges ahead of me my
friends i feel
challenges every day challenges of
hiring keeping the team
together uh you know dealing with all of
the logistics
of taxes and the things i'm a small town
kid college dropout dude
i don't know how to run a company like
great thing to say when you're hiring
sean
like but think about it like i i've got
we're figuring these things out every
single day but our lean as a company is
we're not
we're not a defense company we're an
offense company
we're a wisdom company because we
believe that a healthy team has offense
defense and special teams like a
football team
but our energy is an offense company you
don't win
a game by defense only you have to be on
offense to actually score points
offense lean in take ground take
territory
number one you want to work for think
character is the foundation number two
chemistry you got to be compatible with
our culture
read the the details that work with
think.com number three competency
credibility and you're capable of
getting the job done number four
capacity speed matters and number five
courage
courage all right hey click click the uh
the like button um work
with think dot com
like i don't even know how to run a
company
we've been doing all right so far though
so uh
check us out and you can see the details
there and if you got questions poor four
question marks before or after
we take a couple questions if you have
any questions about what it would be
like to work at think
um if you have any questions about here
we go
uh okay so what are you looking for in a
candidate applying for the social media
specialists regarding what someone has
built does number of subs matter
production value videos matter
influence good so um
well if you okay if you've built your
own social media that could be one type
of portfolio
so yeah it would be it would be the the
attention to the aesthetic
um it would be the attention to like
even thumbnail design
like actually here's a good example like
when we hired tony ariola
um it was not number of subs but it was
discerning that like oh dang he's
putting out good work and eventually the
subs will be there because he has an
aesthetic
on the thumbnails he can communicate
well the organization of the content
now we are not asking with the social
media position that you necessarily
uh have a youtube channel or something
so in regards to what someone has built
it would also be
um have you built up instagram pages
before
are you aware of what's happening on
linkedin have you been effectively
posting content on linkedin
are you good at repurposing content
that's a huge thing we work with a
company called repurpose house
which chops like our big videos into
like two minute clips are you
understanding of
posting clips across platforms in
various formats
vertical on igtv you know
square a lot of places are you good at
using new apps and things to close
caption video files that are chopped
down i'm giving away all the secrets
um you got to come to the job with the
stuff i'm describing
if you haven't read or don't understand
jab jab jab
right hook by gary vaynerchuk then it
wouldn't be the right position for you
not that you have to have known that
exact book
but it's understanding that each social
media platform has a different vibe
and culture itself and so you're
respectful for that and you don't just
blast content across platforms
you understand being native to the
context and the conversation and the
energy of each platform
um and so a portfolio would be here's
some design i've done
here's some um instagram accounts i've
built here's some facebook pages i've
met
managed and the cool thing about that is
you actually can't really
lie in regards to that because all your
work is
being able to be shown right there you
know what i mean it's sort of like
if i was going to hire you to paint my
car you're like here's four other cars
i've painted
oh yeah that looks nice like good around
the edges oh cool like that that's
really good it looks like it's not
chipping off you know
so it's actually looking at what you've
built in terms of
the various social media platforms and
hear me our ambition
is like because we are scaling with the
team is to
um is to hire uh
is to be on all the platforms hear me
youtube creator watching this you cannot
be on i don't believe you can be
all the platforms well when you're a
solo creator but we are a scaling team
so through team gary vaynerchuk i also
would
hope is somebody you follow um and he
has
just kind of the idea of like 100 pieces
of content a day
that's speed and what is 100 pieces of
content a day
you might be like oh dear god i'm not
applying anymore well hear me
so if i do if i do 20 instagram stories
10 instagram stories
that's 20 pieces of content um if if
two three instagram stories hits my
profile that's three more
uh feed posts we will eventually have a
think media instagram
so if one a day hits there you know
that's another one
um if if three micro clips
of videos hit linkedin a day hit
facebook a day
hit uh instagram a day that's another
one
if a youtube shorts gets up late loaded
and that one also hits reels and tick
tock and listen
not all at the same time so if that hits
those different platforms
but the archives and the new ones and
some don't even fit on tick tock but
some might work on tick tock and reels
and youtube shorts
and architecting i'm actually not
necessarily suggesting
well if that if that feels like
challenging and if you if you're even
following me and thinking that way
that's kind of when we think social
media specialists
and also hear me we are a team that
works with
virtual assistants and stuff too so if
you're like holy crap that's more work
than one person could do well first of
all i hope you have the courage and
ambition to just step in and run right
at it
but it's also about smart so it's if
you've set up systems
here you go social media content
calendars i'm giving away all the
secrets you're going to know what to say
in an interview
you just let go of what i'm saying okay
you you know have you created
spreadsheets and schedules
and social media calendars and uh
and calendars around holidays and times
of the year back to jennifer's question
here's kind of what we look for as a
true expert in social media
so uh who do you study
in any of the positions who do you study
so you could get better in those
positions
can a potential candidate work for you
but still have their own channel yep for
sure a lot of
heather has her own channel tony has her
own channel chris says his own chris is
on customer service chris has got an
awesome channel
jordan is our executive assistant she's
got a shakutari channel amazing gray's
boards awesome channel yeah we are
highly encouraging of that
um melee mellie mel
do you have to be based in the u.s um
you don't and so please apply because if
the synergy's there and there's like a
real good
fit there then um
it might work but in terms of meeting
times and whatnot and overlapping of
just times
of of uh like we have a nine o'clock
meeting pacific standard time
three days a week standing standing
meeting short
quick quick one on monday shorter on
wednesday and then we do like a
leadership meeting on friday 9 a.m
pacific standard time
so being at those types of things and
you can apply anyways because some
positions
there's kind of like levels of working
at the company so
that's i just want you to be fully aware
that ideally you can overlap
with our time zones in a uh
a way that's sustainable that's not even
you're like oh just grind all night well
can you do that for a long time so
things like that and um
think about that for the administrative
position if the candidate hasn't worked
with scheduling platforms mentioned
is it a deal breaker well for the
administrative position
um like you can learn things but yeah
you gotta like administrative
coordinator
calendly like google calendar
um and david said with love and respect
um i think
yes those skills are learnable so if
you've got the character and the
chemistry
maybe you could grow into them but like
we're asking for these four positions
again that you've been successful twice
that you've built something
and so things like
somebody who's great at administration
if you and your personal life
aren't using google calendar and having
it like
tell your phone and have organize your
kids and like give you notifications so
you don't miss meetings and time
management
and and and color coding google calendar
and integrating it with other apps well
then that probably is not the right
position
even if you just we're doing that in
your personal life let alone being able
to manage and deconflict
teams and time zones and we have like
talk with think think.com
administrative coordinator those would
be just like i would expect a
videographer
to know the settings of a camera and be
competent with his tools
yes it would matter to know the modern
administrative tools i wouldn't consider
myself a graphic artist but i have a lot
of experience in photoshop lightroom
creating thumbnails social graphics like
that
are you looking for actual artists for
the graphic design position jordan
if your work is good if you're fast if
you can use those tools i mean i
wouldn't consider myself a graphic
artist either
um phil definitely feel free to apply
key his portfolio of what your past
uh work has uh what you've done in the
past like
uh what is a graphic design portfolio
portfolio what must it include
uh your work and here's here's a secret
i'm giving away all the secrets
but here's the secret um
i would look at think media and if you
haven't studied think media that's
probably think one to do
really dug deep not just on our videos
but look at all of our platforms look at
all of our social media
look at links in the description below
and reverse engineer even our style and
our vibe
this is what we would be asking we'd be
asking not that you rebrand our company
but you enhance the brand of our company
you could shift our brand to make it
better make it stronger make it
but but you got to be able to produce
what we're producing right now
so even though it's a secret in plain
sight
it's all right there i guess we're
asking for
is what we're doing already multiplied
so if you can do the thumbnails we're
doing
the graphics we're doing you know across
our
if you look at my instagram you're able
to like reproduce if you see some of
that stuff you're like and by the way if
you go you know i'm taking a different
direction
i mean you can apply but we're looking
to amplify
our company that is very successful with
lots of momentum
so um thumbnails you know websites
you've designed or graphics you've
designed for websites and this might go
into a fact of we are asking you to be a
specialist
and not necessarily wear a ton of hats
but when we say like digital marketing
graphic designer do you know what that
means digital marketing graphic designer
means
um uh
graphic design for facebook ads twitter
ads
instagram ads vertical horizontal so if
you want to if you've been successful
twice
here's here's ads you've done for a
particular person that you did a
marketing campaign for
here's some stuff you did for a dtc or
an e-commerce brand or something
here's some of the ad designs you did
for them here are some of the personal
brand
uh social media graphics you created for
somebody you've worked with in the
past um i hope that helps
cynthia yeah google calendar is a
beautiful tool time
giver if you see any of these verticals
you'd say man i i love all things i
obsess over all things social media
specialists
i obsess over all things digital
marketing graphic designer
um and by the way i mean sometimes your
ambition and your courage
and your gumption can be uh can say a
lot so
if you want to apply work with think dot
com do you work with college
students sure read the job descriptions
if you've got the hours and the ability
to do it
awesome excuse me what are you looking
for applying for the administrative
coordinator and will the position
be open to other countries best thing to
do is to click on the position
and then just read it it says it all
right here uh it says you may be in
enneagram too
like wow details of the role 30 hours
per week monday through friday pst
so it is remote but you'd need to work
during those times
so it's all here so i've actually
probably said too much um
work with think.com if you're serious if
you want to apply
uh go to workwiththink.com we are hiring
four positions
uh one position yes jordan good good
clarity one position
uh one person per position and you know
things
like i don't know like i guess if it
really makes sense and there's really a
vibe and like 20 hours makes sense i
mean it says it on here but some of them
can grow into
into we don't really want to split it up
basically it's it's all there it's all
on it's all on the website
i will stop adding words to what is
already clear by the team on
workwiththink.com
did you catch the website yet text is
above me on facebook and then below me
on
youtube work with think.com are you
filling the positions as soon as
possible yeah
uh we are um it's gonna probably be a
couple week
if not month and a half process uh
they'll be back and forth
there'll be different rounds you'll be
notified via email
uh if you made it to like the next round
or whatever um
and then we do higher slow so i would
expect that we want to lock these
positions in the next two months and
there'll be a lot of kind of back and
forth but also be patient for example we
lob this out
and our team has really good rest ethic
they're they're camping and they're
doing some things this weekend
so if you like you don't get an instant
response it's the weekend
like we are with our families um
and if you don't get a response on
monday it's because we are not
gathered we're gonna look at all of them
at the end of the week so just be
patient
um don't feel uh bad about inquiring
more or whatever but uh
uh check all that uh out um
yeah dimitri um sometime we
are potentially looking at expanding to
a video editor not at this time
and specifically for repurposing and
chopping up a ton of
youtube shorts um instagram reels a lot
of repurposing
and basically execution on short form
vertical content across platforms
um so hey
if you got value today hit the like
button if you want to watch the replay
um it's five c's i think
let me know what your aha moment was
friends uh
for um um today did you learn
anything or i hope was encouraged or
maybe challenged just to level up in
your own personal life your own personal
leadership or for
you as a solo creator as a solopreneur
um
did you feel challenged to level up uh
in your current job did you
do you think that uh some of the c's do
you think they're powerful do you think
that
um would you like to work at think media
why would you like to work at think
media
what was a um an aha moment that you had
today during this stream
um and uh
and so um let me know in aha moment the
entire video tony says i appreciate you
tony thanks for being here
i'm glad that this i hope it also had
value thank you symphony thanks so much
for being here hit like
and um and listen you know at the end of
the day
uh chemistry we
love all people from all different kind
of backgrounds
there's all kinds of different companies
there's all kinds of different vibes
i hope this video gives you a little bit
of
my heart so you kind of know what to
expect because why not get to sit down
with me i realize this is mostly a
one-way conversation
but if you go i could i could roll with
that like i i like that energy i like i
like what things doing
um i like the 5cs i think i think that'd
be a good fit if so
think work with think.com
and uh and pay attention to detail check
it definitely out
uh and uh would love to to connect
character chemistry competency capacity
and courage
um volunteers and apprentices yes not
right now
so as we build we eventually someday
will have um
where it'll probably be an in-person
internship in vegas
like apprentice volunteer type of a
thing um
and that might not even be this year and
of course
you know covet and who knows but but uh
absolutely that'll be happening in the
future but right now there's four
positions we're looking for one
person for each position if you're
interested uh
you know work with think.com liz it
would be a dream come true
well liz uh hit the website up uh we'd
love to learn more from you
get to know you a little bit uh we've
learned all of sean's secrets
it's true you learned i hope it was
helpful uh youth fluential
some leadership stuff i've learned over
the years and stuff that i hope
makes our healthy our team a healthy
culture and a growing leadership culture
um and uh really really appreciate you
well hey
thanks for uh hanging out keep crushing
it keep smashing it check the replay
um and if you uh are feeling bold and
like it's good alignment
hit me up work with think.com
peace